[Music]
in 1995
catelyn carrico had hit a low point a
biochemist at the university of
pennsylvania
she devoted her entire career to turning
mrna
one of the most important building
blocks of life into a whole new field of
medicine
but it just wasn't happening everybody
argued that the rna is
so transient and degraded and it will
never be
it never be a medicine i knew that
it can be used for everything and you
know kind of a cassandra feeling that
i can see the future and nobody believes
me
carrico's grant applications were
rejected she was demoted endured a
cancer scare but she stuck with it
she spent weekends and holidays doing
research and experiments
and in 2005 carrico and her colleague
drew weisman published a breakthrough
study
confirming the therapeutic use of mrna
research which would underpin the
success
of mrna covered vaccines today when the
first covid19 vaccine was approved i was
extremely excited
i thought it was a changed moment for
mrna
what we've been seeing in animals was
real it works in people and that's the
most
important thing mrna has gone from a
rejected idea
to a powerful weapon helping to end the
pandemic
and applications of this technology
could provide a cure for diseases beyond
covid
[Music]
messenger rna or mrna is a genetic
material that copies instructions from
our dna
our cells use these instructions to make
proteins which carry out different
functions in the human body
mrnas are responsible for everything our
body does
from breathing air to eating food
to walking to sleeping to thinking
covert vaccines from pfizer biontec and
moderna are based on this mrna mechanism
unlike traditional vaccines using dead
or weakened viruses
mrna vaccines use the genetic
information of the virus
scientists make an mrna that codes for
the spike protein of sars cov2
the virus that caused covid19 then the
mrna is put inside a lipid coating and
injected into the human body
the cell reads the mrna and starts to
make harmless spike proteins of its own
which triggers the immune system to
produce antibodies against the virus
the way that mrna vaccines work are
similar to really all vaccines
what they're doing is they're presenting
a protein or proteins from a pathogen
and they're causing our bodies to make
an immune response
against those proteins or protein when
you make
a an inactivated virus vaccine
you have to isolate the virus you have
to grow it up in eggs
you have to figure out how to grow it in
eggs
you have to purify it and activate it
and formulate it with mrna
you only need the sequence you don't
need the virus
so it's a very simple vaccine to make
this means that making mrna vaccines is
faster than making traditional ones
but the journey for mrna to break into
mainstream medicine has been long and
challenging
mrna was first discovered in 1961
but it wasn't until 1984 that scientists
were able to recreate it in the lab
in the 1990s as scientists knew more
about the makeup of human dna
gene therapy became popular inserting a
gene into a patient's cells to treat or
prevent disease
but most researchers gave little thought
to using mrna as a vaccine or a drug
despite its close relationship with dna
i
argued that the messenger rna is more
like a conventional drug
you can apply and then if you see
beneficial effect you can reapply
and then the healing is done rather than
a gene therapy
where you are delivering the gene and
and you cannot control
but many rejected carrico's idea arguing
mrna therapies didn't look feasible
the immune system is hyper vigilant
against foreign rna entering the body
and so the injected lab-made rna caused
inflammation
which destroyed it before it could start
to trigger an immune response
and even worse that inflammation could
be life-threatening
[Music]
1997 carrico met drew weissman
a respected immunologist and they
started to collaborate
the big discovery was we figured out by
modifying the nucleus side so rna has
four letters that code for a protein
each letter is a nucleoside or a base
we modified those bases and that
reduced and got rid of the inflammation
when we altered uridine and we
had pseudoiridin we found that not only
we have rna which is non-immunogenic but
we had very high level of protein
production
the amount of protein made from the rna
increases about a thousand fold
you get rid of inflammation and you
increase potency
in the same step so it was like
a dream come true they published the key
research and filed a patent which was
later licensed to moderna and biontech
the companies making mrna covert
vaccines today
carrico also started to work for biontec
in 2013
but there was another hurdle how to
deliver mrna to targeted cells
mrna is notoriously fragile and enzymes
in the human body can break it down
so you really need to have it protected
from the enzymes and other kinds of
things in the body
you could call them the bad guy so to
speak and if you don't
then the therapy won't work at all it
would be non-existent
as early as the 1970s chemical engineer
robert langer and his colleague judah
folkman
proved that it's possible to deliver
molecules like rna
inside tiny particles without destroying
them
the nanoparticles langer used were made
of polymers
not lipids as used in today's mrna
covert vaccines
so we were trying to put dna and rna
into tiny particles and deliver them
i i failed the first 200 times when i
did it and
by the way that was also widely
criticized so i got my
first nine grants turned down i couldn't
get a job and
a you know faculty job in a chemical
engineering department which was my
area but today langer is a renowned
scientist with over 900 issued patents
in 2010 he co-founded moderna and still
sits on its board
after decades of development the main
biological roadblocks were cleared
but mrna technology had never been used
outside of clinical trials until
recently
in the last few minutes we've heard that
the first coronavirus vaccine has been
approved for use in the uk
this has been manufactured by the u.s
pharmaceutical company pfizer
and by on tech and here is the first
person in line
to get it
in the following months mrna vaccines
from both pfizer biontec and moderna
were cleared in multiple countries
taking less than a year from the lab
into people's arms
these are the fastest vaccines that have
ever been developed
both with a 95 efficacy rate
but some people are concerned that these
vaccines are hastily made the
speed of making the vaccine the the 10
months that it took
there's very good reasons that people
need to understand why that happened
it was an emergency it was a pandemic
all of the clinical trials were done
at the same time all of the testing
was done together no corners were cut
there was no safety issues that were
ignored
everything was done exactly the same as
every other vaccine
in december 2020 carrico and wiseman
were given the covert vaccines they had
contributed to
and the people were waiting the health
care workers in the
in line there to get their vaccine and
you know they clapped
and then then i cried
about 3.2 billion doses of mrna cova
vaccines are expected to be given
in 2021 and now mrna may
also be used to help fight future
pandemics and diseases that current
medicines struggle to treat
the mrna is just an instruction
for the cell to make the protein we can
targeting the messenger rna to certain
organs certain cell types
bone marrow and and then can perform
different kind of treatment there are
many different applications for
messenger rna i mean and
you know at moderna they're working on
heart disease they're working on
personalized cancer vaccines they're
working on
rare diseases i think the next big
act for rna are probably going to be
more vaccines
last summer we started working on a pan
coronavirus vaccine
so there have been three coronavirus
epidemics and pandemics in the past 20
years
you have to assume there's going to be
more can we make a vaccine
that prevents against all of those bat
coronaviruses
that have the potential to infect people
and start another epidemic or pandemic
i think that the pan influenza and pan
coronavirus
are going to be the most exciting rna
vaccines to come out in the future
mrna has been proven now now as a really
impressive and powerful new technology
and and the application of mrna
goes of course very straight approaches
to develop
mrna vaccines against other infectious
diseases
and we are already doing that yeah we
have started that
early on for developing influenza
based mrna vaccines we are developing
mrna vaccines against tuberculosis
against hiv
biotech has also been studying the
technology in cancer for two decades
and has a cancer vaccine in phase 2
clinical trials
they're hoping the cancer field might
see its first messenger rna drug
approvals in two or three years
there's no guarantee that other mrna
vaccines and drugs will succeed like
they have with covert 19
but carrick remains undaunted by the
challenge
that's the most important things to
accomplish something and meanwhile to be
happy
as long as i was in the lab i had fun
it is just such a joy even if
things didn't work out how i expected
you